jeffrey we're in time pressure in
another game so we don't have much time
but you did have an opportunity here
two opportunities in fact queen c2 and
the way you played f4 knight takes and
queen f3 looks like it would have been
advantageous for you when you played
here queen d2 did you think that i just
had to shut this position down or just
uh didn't see his knight d3 uh yeah i
completely blundered at knight d3 um i
definitely thought
i was uh much better after queen d2 but
yeah 93 was kind of a cold shower for me
there's been some half points you've
missed in this tournament you could have
drawn against dariush with a bishop d4
move now this one
got to be a little bit under the skin
seeing that there's a couple of moments
you could have had a much better score
yeah that's true after i would say i was
very lucky to uh to survive against
shanklin but yeah as you mentioned maybe
these uh the game against schwertz maybe
wesley against wesley could have done
better
but uh yeah i mean it's part of the
tournament yeah it is what it is do you
feel like you're getting a little bit
closer take some lessons from this game
to prepare you to be stronger for the
future
oh for sure yeah coming here to play uh
36 games i guess against these guys is
just
huge for uh for my chess development so
yeah the more games i get the more i
learn
all right well good luck tomorrow thanks
very very quick question for you jeffrey
because we're almost out of time
uh you're feeling you've played 2 800
grand masters you played 2700 grand
masters what's the big difference
between those two weight divisions
yeah i don't know it's hard to say um
i would say that the when i play this
event it feels like you know there isn't
too big of a gap i mean we're all human
we're all making mistakes so
yeah it's very hard to say
okay thank you and good luck tomorrow